From more superhero movies to down-to-earth
dramas and everything in between, here are
all the movies that are set to blow you away
in summer of 2019.
Kicking off summer on May 31 is Godzilla:
King of the Monsters, the follow-up to the
well-received 2014 movie about the legendary
kaiju. The movie is the third installment
in Legendary Entertainment's MonsterVerse,
following up on 2017's Kong: Skull Island
and setting up an eventual battle between
the two monsters in 2020's Godzilla vs. Kong.
"This island is just the beginning."
"There's more out there."
"What do you mean, more?"
"This world never belonged to us. It belonged
to them."
Hopefully that movie can live up to what we
got the last time Godzilla and King Kong threw
down:
On top of bringing back characters from the
2014 Godzilla, the sequel is bringing in a
roster of fan favorite actors, including Stranger
Things' Millie Bobby Brown, Bates Motel's
Vera Farmiga, and Friday Night Lights' Kyle
Chandler. Together, they play a family swept
up in the crisis that the monsters of the
title cause, adding a human element to what
promises to be a larger-than-life slugfest.
Also coming out on June 7 is Long Shot, a
big-screen comedy team-up starring Seth Rogen
and Charlize Theron. It comes from a script
by The Interview writer Dan Sterling, which
made the Black List collection of hottest
unproduced screenplays in 2011.
The movie stars Rogen as an out of work journalist
named Fred Flarsky who, after getting fed
up with his bad luck and self-destructive
ways, decides he's going to finally pursue
his longtime crush: a former babysitter from
his childhood. The only problem? She's since
become one of the most powerful women in the
world, as well as a presidential candidate.
Will he succeed in winning her affections?
We don't know, but it'll probably be funny
to see him try.
Sony is bringing back the Men in Black series
with a new spinoff on June 14. The latest
take on the comic book adaptation will take
the series beyond the bounds of New York City,
telling a story on a more global scale.
Subbing for Tommy Lee Jones, Will Smith, and
Josh Brolin this time will be Thor: Ragnarok
co-stars Chris Hemsworth and Tessa Thompson.
They'll be joined in the cast by Emma Thompson,
no relation, who's returning to her role as
the MiB chief Agent O.
Thanks to their shared screen time in the
Marvel universe, we know the two leads have
great chemistry. But the movie will reportedly
focus on not just them, but a whole ensemble
of characters, building out the super-secret
organization with a cast of fresh faces. It's
all being brought to life by Fate of the Furious
director F. Gary Gray, who's teased that International
will take the series to a fresh new place
while still staying true to the movies that
came before it.
The Men in Black aren't the only cool, calm
and collected characters coming back on June
14. There's also a new movie about Shaft.
"You know, they say that cat Shaft is one
bad mother—"
"Shut up you guys!"
"What's going on?"
"We're just talking about Shaft."
"I can dig it."
The film been described as a direct sequel
to the Shaft movie from 2000, which starred
Samuel L. Jackson as John Shaft the Second,
nephew of the original Shaft played by Richard
Roundtree. In keeping with that tradition,
the new movie will focus on John Shaft the
Third an FBI agent and cybersecurity expert
played by Jessie T. Usher.
Both Roundtree and Jackson are making appearances
in the new movie, which will see three generations
of Shaft teaming up to crack a mystery. It
sounds like more style than one movie can
handle.
"Sty-lin'."
For American audiences, Shaft will be getting
a full theatrical rollout, but viewers outside
the country will be able to see it on Netflix
on June 28.
Thirty-one years after the original Child's
Play first gave him life, Chucky's coming
back to the big screen on June 21. After seven
movies in the same continuity, the original
story is finally getting the remake treatment,
this time without the involvement of of creator
Don Mancini or longtime Chucky voice actor
Brad Dourif.
On top of a new creative team, the remake
also features a deeply unsettling redesign
for the series' iconic Good Guys doll, which
will be called a Buddi doll in the new film,
adding a new level of wide-eyed innocence
to the serial-killer-possessed toy.
"Hi, I'm Chucky. Wanna play?"
"AAAH!"
The Conjuring cinematic universe continues
to grow with a third entry in the Annabelle
series, promising that 2019 will be a banner
year for horror movies about creepy dolls.
The new installment is a follow-up to the
2017 prequel, Annabelle: Creation, and is
set for release on July 3. The new movie will
bring the series forward in time to The Conjuring
territory with appearances from Patrick Wilson
and Vera Farmiga's Ed and Lorraine Warren,
who eventually end up in possession of the
haunted doll.
“Where's the doll now?"
"Someplace safe."
The story for the sequel has been described
as Annabelle meets Night at the Museum. It'll
feature the haunted doll exerting its twisted
influence inside of the Warrens' cluttered
artifact room, bringing evil to life to terrorize
the couple's young daughter and her babysitters.
In other words, it's time for the Warrens'
kid to take up the family business of hunting
demons this summer, whether she's ready for
the job or not.
Tom Holland's Spider-Man is set to continue
his adventures in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with a a second standalone film on July 5,
2019. After taking some detours with the Avengers
and, uh, getting killed for a little while,
the new movie will take the webslinger back
to basics with another hit of action-comedy
from the creative team behind Spider-Man:
Homecoming.
Despite the familiarity behind the scenes,
the new Spider-Man adventure will feel different
from all of the character's previous movies,
taking him outside of his Queens neighborhood
and across the ocean to Europe. While he's
there, he'll face off with the villainous
Mysterio, a trickster character from Marvel
Comics being brought into live-action for
the first time, fishbowl and all, by Jake
Gyllenhaal.
We've all had our share of Uber horror stories:
the driver goes the long way around the city
to the airport, and you almost miss your flight,
takes one too many back-road "shortcuts" and
gets completely lost, thus sending you spiraling
into a mini-meltdown in the backseat, or asks
way too many questions that you weren't prepared
to answer after dancing and drinking the night
away. It's almost as if the outcome of an
Uber ride is determined by the flip of a coin:
it's either easy-breezy or kind of a disaster.
In Stuber, it's the latter, only it's the
driver who's subject to all sorts of unforeseen
troubles.
Helmed by Future Man and Take Me Home Tonight
director Michael Dowse, Stuber centers on
an unsuspecting Uber driver named Stu, played
by Kumail Nanjiani who picks up his rider,
Vic, played by Dave Bautista, a detective
who's chasing down a dangerous terrorist.
Chaos ensues when Stu gets tangled in Vic's
dangerous ordeal, and tries to keep his nerves
level, himself alive, and his coveted five-star
rating intact.
Accept the ride Stuber is offering when it
hits theaters on July 12.
Love him or hate him, Quentin Tarantino is
one of the most interesting living filmmakers,
and he's coming out with a new movie on July
26. After making two straight movies set in
the old west, Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
is hearkening back to ground the director
last covered in Pulp Fiction. Once Upon a
Time is still a period piece, though, this
one set in the wild year of 1969.
The story will focus on an out-of-work TV
actor played by Leonardo DiCaprio, who's looking
to step away from show business. His sidekick
and stunt double Cliff Booth, played by Brad
Pitt, is feeling the same way. Their journey
will intersect somehow with the Manson Family
murders, with the notorious killings said
to serve as a backdrop of sorts to the main
story.
If the concept isn't enticing enough, then
you might be interested in the movie's dazzling
cast. In addition to Pitt, DiCaprio, and Margot
Robbie as the doomed Sharon Tate, the movie
also features appearances from James Marsden,
Dakota Fanning, Damian Lewis, Timothy Olyphant,
Burt Reynolds, and Al Pacino, among others.
And that's just a small sample; the movie
will also feature the return of previous collaborators
Kurt Russell, Michael Madsen, and Tim Roth.
Tarantino has long contended that he plans
to retire from filmmaking after ten movies.
Whether that turns out being true or not,
it sounds like movie number nine has everyone
in Hollywood wanting to be a part of it.
The Fast and the Furious franchise is taking
a year off in 2019, kind of. The summer will
see the first spinoff in the vehicular mayhem
franchise, this time focusing on Dwayne Johnson
and Jason Statham's characters, Luke Hobbs
and Deckard Shaw.
The movie comes from a script from Chris Morgan,
who's been with the franchise since Tokyo
Drift, and promises to team up the two fan-favorite
characters in what sounds like The Odd Couple
on steroids.The movie is directed by John
Wick and Deadpool 2 helmer David Leitch, which
has us hoping for both elegant action and
some biting wit. Idris Elba being on board
to play the movie's main villain is just the
cherry on top. The spinoff kicks off August
2, and can't get here fast enough.
"Who the hell are you?”
“Bad guy."
August 2 will also see the release of New
Mutants, a comic book horror hybrid directed
by Josh Boone. Splintering off from the main
X-Men narrative, New Mutants will introduce
a group of superpowered teens who are forced
to reconcile their powers and past sins after
they're captured and held in a mysterious
secret facility.
The new mutants on deck to appear include
Sunspot, who can turn into a ball of dangerous
UV radiation, Mirage, a spooky soothsayer,
and a shape-shifting robot named Warlock.
The cast includes Maisie Williams from Game
of Thrones, Charlie Heaton from Stranger Things,
and Anya Taylor-Joy from The Witch, Glass,
and Split.
The movie has reportedly been through reshoots,
allegedly to both add a whole new character
and make the movie scarier.
Whatever the real reasons behind the push
back, the film still looks interesting, and
will hopefully bring something new to the
crowded superhero genre as the summer draws
to a close.
Millions of readers around the world are familiar
with Eoin Colfer's Artemis Fowl novels, which
followed a precocious criminal mastermind
over a series of globetrotting adventures.
The fantasy series has always seemed ripe
for the big-screen treatment, but for whatever
reason, an adaptation never took off, until
now.
Walt Disney's cinematic take on the first
two books is being directed by Kenneth Branagh,
known to mainstream audiences for his work
directing Thor and Murder on the Orient Express,
and for that time he showed up in Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets. The lead role
is set to be played by Irish newcomer Ferdia
Shaw, with Judi Dench playing a gender-swapped
version of the books' Commander Root.
With such a beloved book property, the pressure's
on to make fans happy. We'll see if the filmmakers
pull it off when the movie is released on
August 9.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel, and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.